we're making it so hard for this to
happen brothers are starting to have
secret marriages
secret arrangements um
because they know
because you told him
you ever do that i'm out
you ever do that i'm not gonna let you
see your kids you ever do that i'm gonna
do x y and z and you think that you've
won
sis
like i said
let the hate come
but this is not
the mindset
of the women of islam
this is not the mindset of the sahabiat
it's not the mindset of the wives of the
prophet hashem and the thing is sisters
we like to use the seerah when it suits
us
we want to use the seerah
and tell brothers you should be marrying
divorcees you should be marrying widows
you shouldn't have a problem with
marrying sisters who are overweight
sisters who are old sisters who have
kids you shouldn't marry but you
shouldn't worry because the prophet saws
did it
and it feels good to do that doesn't it
but what about the other way around
what about if someone said to you you
should be glad if your husband wants to
take the responsibility of another woman
you should be offering him to other
sisters you should want for your sister
what you want for yourself you should be
welcoming those sisters into your house
like those women did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i remember fired saying that even the
muslim space is a gynocentric space
which i had never heard before um that's
not an idea that i had come across but
do you think it's because
muslim men feel
that they can't really talk publicly
about these types of
men are dealing with and sort of say
something that might upset people or get
them cancelled what are your thoughts of
course of course i remember our our
first episode why believe in islam
okay oh sorry why believe in god a lot
of people vibe with it a second episode
why believe in islam why islam is truth
okay a lot of atheists and islamophobes
kind of left but most people vibed with
it third one lgbt the alphabet people a
lot of people didn't vibe with that one
the fourth one
um
i'm okay with the backlash from episode
one two and three the fourth one which
is talking about polygeny most of the
backlash was from muslim women
right so we can't spit game about
polygamy without getting cancelled
basically
exactly
and permissible we can't even talk about
that makes no sense even there's there's
different tafsir on on the on surah nisa
where allah says
and marry two or three or four if you
can then marry one that the default
state is supposed to be polygyny but
that's that's a different conversation
but just they're acting like it's it's
like haram
a lot of them and we can't even talk
about issues i actually have
you know a different view
on
on
polygeny polygamy
um i have a couple of
observations
okay one is that
polygyny i still can't call it pillaging
to be honest
that's such an american thing although i
know it's the correct phrase
but if we look at it on a societal level
my my people are my mother's people are
zulu right
zulus don't have a cap on polygamy right
polygamous families can go up to 20
women if you can afford it so there's no
cap as long as you can afford to pay the
bride price you get in it
same you'll see the king of swaziland
he's got like 28 wives or something like
that
correct me in the comments if i'm wrong
so
on a societal level
polygamy or polygyny operates in favor
of women and children
a lot of people don't want to hear that
a lot of women yes my sisters
you don't want to hear that
because
you believe in
the hollywood
romantic disney ideal of one man who
loves you and only you
and that your marriage is based on your
feelings of romantic love
and that this man will pledge to be true
to you forever
and you will be happily ever after like
in the fairy tale very stories right
the reality is that
this model of marriage is very new
and it's it's new even in the west
because outside of the west people have
always known you don't marry for love
you marry
to make a deal
you marry to have a family you marry to
uh to create ties of kinship you marry
to protect you marry for protection you
marry for provision you marry so that
you can have your own family and leave
your parents house there were many many
many reasons why traditionally men and
women would marry
nothing to do with love
nothing to do with romance
very little to do with game and the the
zinger zing and any of those feelings
right
people got married because that was the
thing to do and you will choose your
partner hoping that you will have the
most secure situation possible so you
could raise your children in security
and be able to see them to adulthood and
fulfill your role as an adult in your
society right so across the world
that is why people got married not
because they were in love with each
other and not because they wanted to
ride off into the sunset but because
that's what you do and marriage is a
duty it has responsibilities it you know
it's families coming together it's just
way bigger than the zingersing
now
come to where we find ourselves now
having been indoctrinated myself and you
guys included with the idea that
marriage is all about love and how you
feel and this romantic ideal of the one
man and one woman who are soul mates and
the one and the one who's written for
you and all of this kind of thing
of course no woman wants
that to be impacted no woman wants to
share her husband
the only reason you say i don't want to
share my husband is because you see him
as yours in the first place but that's a
social construct
am i wrong guys sorry am i am i just
pure nonsense here no no no go ahead
it's a social construct
and
the monogamous model
some would argue from a socio
socio-economic point of view that it has
its benefits etcetera i don't really
want to go into that but what i will say
to my sisters and to us as women
understand yeah that your desire to have
that man to yourself has been bred into
you okay not to say jealousy is not a
thing but if you grew up in a society
where polygeny was the norm like in many
parts of the world northern nigeria i
know so many wonderful sisters from
northern nigeria who grew up with two
mothers or three mothers that was the
norm
you wouldn't even have an idea that i
will marry a muslim man and i'll be the
only one right but here we are we're in
modern society we've been bred how we're
bred and that's what we believe now
the
cultural context in many of especially
in the west but any modern muslim
society
monogamy
is modern polygamy is backward
right yes
because monogamy is how white people do
things monogamy is how the west portrays
the ideal relationship right it's
monogamous um and polygamy is backward
polygamy is like this old patriarchal
tradition and all of this kind of thing
and really we need to evolve past
polygamy etc but really what a
long story short what i'm trying to say
is
when we agree
to that model of monogamous marriage
being the ideal
what we are effectively doing is we are
cutting off
all the women
and the children that could have been
under the protection of that man because
that doesn't fit our life goals that
doesn't fit the way that we want to live
it doesn't fit the way we want to run
our families and that's why i say that
polygamy actually operates for the
benefit of women and children because if
one man
can safely look after two three or four
women and have children with two three
or four women and run his family
correctly is that not better than him
only having one wife
and having children with that one
on a societal level
not to mention divorcees and single
mothers and sisters who can't have kids
and sisters who are older
yeah
let me ask you a question i
i get this a lot from sisters and they
say okay i understand why allah made
polygyny halal and permissible however i
think it was more relevant back then
more men died in battle in war there
were more women than men the times were
tough society wasn't as
uh i guess convenient and safe therefore
you know having more uh women per man
makes sense and today it's less of the
need basis and more of just pleasure or
dunya related basis what would you say
to that
tell that to the sisters who are in
their 30s who haven't been able to find
the husband
still of their own
tell that to the sisters who maybe were
in a marriage it did not work out and
now she's here by herself
full responsibility for two three four
children with no man in her life
tell that to those sisters who are
lonely tell them to those sisters who
have no protection who have no one who
will call them up and ask them are you
okay nobody to bring groceries nobody to
have a word with the kids i'm sorry but
unless you've been there
don't talk yeah because
the reality for single muslim women
especially older ones you know what this
is really interesting because
young women in general
think they are invincible
i don't need a man
those are the ones you hear saying i
don't need no man
because i guess you don't you can safely
go from your house to your office to the
club to wherever you want to go for it
you don't need a man for that you pay
your own bills you got your own car
you've got your own business you go i'm
you know like i'm cool young women talk
that talk a lot alhamdulillah for youth
right
you wait until that sister is nearing
the wall
you wait and listen to how the story
changes if you're trying to tell me yeah
that there isn't a need today for more
responsible
responsible muslim men to stand up and
say i am going to take on the
responsibility of another family tell me
when you go on the dating apps how many
of those brothers are out there how many
men to women
how many men who are in a position to
get married compared to the number of
women that are trying to get married
this unfortunately for us and this is
something that you know we've been
speaking about unfortunately for us as
women
there comes a time in your life when the
realities of your situation cannot be
ignored anymore
they can't be ignored anymore you can't
finesse your way out of it if you wanted
to have children and for whatever reason
you weren't interested before you know
you were doing your own thing or
whatever and you get to a certain age
and it hasn't happened for you you are
facing the possibility of never having
children
and believe it or not for some women
that's a pretty big deal
you know you're facing there are sisters
out there who are 42 year old virgins
because they never had that opportunity
for whatever reason are we saying to all
these sisters basically no that's you
all the men are taken
and no we don't want any second wives
around here so skedaddle
or just go and mess with these guys who
don't have the skills to be husbands who
who are not in any way capable of
looking after a woman yeah okay marry
one of those ones one of the rejects the
ones that nobody wanted and all this
time they're still looking for somebody
i'm not expecting people's emotions to
change but what i do know is this and
i'll go on record saying this
there's two things that need to happen
for polygyny to start becoming a viable
option in our communities
one brothers need to develop the mindset
of the of koem yeah that's the first
thing the second is first wives need to
understand how to play their role
this whole thing of a second wife coming
in and there being a competition all of
a sudden and now you you know you're
doubting yourself and you you know all
this the emotional stuff that happens
with the first and the second
i remember having this conversation with
somebody and i said look
everyone has to play their role play
your part if your wife number one you
probably have seniority you have tenure
you have children with him you have a
history with him you know him in and out
this second wife can't cut she can't
step to you she can't compete with you
when it comes to those things so play to
your strengths
and don't allow yourself to destroy your
family because of this thing don't give
up everything that you've built over the
past 10 20 years because this thing has
happened which is halal and if it's done
correctly with the right intention allah
will put barakah in it let's not make
any mistakes about this and then the
second wife who comes in who's feeling
you know
insecure because she's comparing herself
to the first one so she's acting out i
say to her the same thing says play to
your strengths you're the new kid on the
block you don't have the kids with him
it's all new it's a new adventure play
to your strengths okay this is what
you're here for you do your part number
one wife and number two why you do your
part and in that way
purify your intentions because it's like
anger was saying you know like this
dunya subhanallah like we as human
beings are making this so complicated
we're making it so hard we're making it
sister sorry i know you're gonna hate
this right and i'm so sorry but i i i'm
speaking what i truly believe here
we are making it so hard for husbands to
take on another
responsibility you know
i i i want people to understand this
that
taking another wife islamically is not
the same as him having an affair
it's not the same as him having a side
chick it's not the same as him sleeping
around you need to get that that model
out of your head
my guy has stepped up to take
responsibility for another woman and if
she has children he's stepping up to
take responsibility for her of course he
should make sure that he's able to step
up but if he is
we're making it so hard for this to
happen brothers are starting to have
secret marriages
secret arrangements um
because they know
because you told him
you ever do that i'm out
you ever do that i'm not gonna let you
see your kids you ever do that i'm gonna
do x y and z and you think that you've
won
sis
like i said
let the hate come but this is not
the mindset
of the women of islam
this is not the mindset of the sahabiat
it's not the mindset of the wives of the
prophet sallam and the thing is sisters
we like to use the seerah when it suits
us
we want to use the seerah
and tell brothers you should be marrying
divorcees you should be marrying widows
you shouldn't have a problem with
marrying sisters who are overweight
sisters who are old sisters who have
kids you shouldn't marry but you
shouldn't worry because the prophet saws
did it
and it feels good to do that doesn't it
but what about the other way around
what about if someone said to you you
should be glad if your husband wants to
take the responsibility of another woman
you should be offering him to other
sisters you should want for your sister
what you want for yourself you should be
welcoming those sisters into your house
like those women did
doesn't feel so good then does it but
that's the reality
this this dunya is a place of test and
examination it is not a place of
fulfillment of desires and feeding the
nufs
and what i don't like what i'm seeing is
a culture amongst the muslims where all
we do is talk about nafs
how i feel how i want how it feels to me
and what i want and me me me me me
not realizing that
there's a whole context here there's a
whole ummah here and you're part of it
your children are part of it and i i'm
never speaking
not knowing how many if you know horror
stories there are about polygamy we all
have heard them
but i want to ask i want to challenge
every brother or sister who is
perpetuating this this idea within our
community that polygamy is damaging that
it creates suicidal depressed first
wives that it's always uh you know the
man taking advantage of a woman who
didn't know better that a woman is is is
marrying down if she agrees to be a
second wife that she's humiliating
herself all of that stuff that's our
contemporary muslim cultural narrative
and where does that come from in the
deen
[Music]
is a
like
a marriage game for poliginous women
i like this
she said if you're the first wife then
like unless like except the second wife
in with open arms but play to your
strengths
this is this is game for the collision
is with muslim women
all the brother has to do i'm sorry i
got so heated yeah all the brother has
to do
do right by your first family
that is the first thing
make sure you are taking care of that
woman
you're taking care of those kids you're
being the best husband you can be to her
because once you've done that
you can do
many things are open to you and nobody
can say anything to you but if you're
not looking after her if you're not
looking after your kids if you're not
you know you're not being the man you
need to be in your first wife in your
first family then don't come out here
saying yeah i need a second one because
uh you already failed in the first test
so let's let's let's keep it a buck you
know what i mean
yeah subhanallah you know uh a lot of
this as you were speaking with allah it
really started to sound more and more
and more like an issue of al-qaeda and
if you compare and contrast islam with
like liberalism islam is very very
community
uh central it's like
community focused it's preventative of
of haram
and it's focused on the greater good of
the entire community but liberalism is
just focused on not even the greater
good of the individual what the
individual wants now that's problematic
because if every individual wants
something different what the heck's
going to happen to society you know
that's very dangerous so when you come
into life from an islamic perspective
you come into life from the perspective
of i want what's best for literally the
human race not just human race but the
earth the animals everything and that is
a lot more beautiful than i want to
fulfill my desires and feel you know
xyz all the good very sad
i want to uh i want to also give an
example you see this a lot on the news
you know there's a shooting here there's
a shooting there's a stabbing here
there's a terrorist attack there you
hear this so much you start to think
it's happening all the time everywhere
but it's not and a lot of the time with
bad relationships the ones with the
worst ones tend to have the loudest
voices and they speak the most so
the woman the woman with the good
politicians relationships not going to
come out and say that i'm having a great
experience because one they don't people
don't generally like to talk about the
great in their life all the time
especially if it's against the norm
because that woman would get flamed
because women get flamed for just saying
i'm a housewife i'm gonna stay at home
mom they get slain for that so now
imagine saying i'm a stay-at-home mom
with another stay-at-home mom that's
like
it's like open open fire on her may
allah you know protect the women i mean
so it's as long as she doesn't do
antique talk it's okay yeah yeah
uh so
yeah at the end of the day
it seems like these things happen a lot
they're failing a lot you hear a lot
about you know people in abu dhabi um
having secret uh kneecaps and marriages
and then forgetting their first wife
allah
two threes and fours if you cannot be
just between them marry only one and
that's the direct command from allah you
are it's haram for you to marry someone
else if you can't be just you will
you're sinful for that as a man now if
you and by the way i want to say
politically from a non-islamic
perspective is not pelogeny
it's not absolutely from a non-islamic
perspective of just having multiple
partners or wives where you're not
fulfilling the responsibility not being
just that is not poligy so when we say
polygyny we're not talking about one man
multiple women
we're talking about islam where you have
as the sister said rights
responsibilities authority and with the
authority comes that responsibility and
more families more people who are being
taken care of and that is a very
beautiful thing and i'd like to memorize
that sister may allah bless you for that
sorry assistant yeah i think there's a
problem this disconnect with a lot of
the sisters out here
who are at the wall
nearing the wall or have passed the wall
and they don't understand like the
reality
of their situation
you know like i know this brother i'm
gonna just leave it like that i know his
brother
who
[Music]
this uh he was talking to his sister
and
him and the sister they were you know
hitting it off but the sister has
she's basically at her wall where she's
passive she's like 30 something she has
two kids she's divorced but he was
hitting it over her and
he was more than ready to marry her
but he said that he wanted to have a
politionist
no she wanted to have like multiple
wives and
she said that she she only wanted one
like she only she wanted to be the only
one and
i don't think she understood
his uh or her situation and the whole
matter was like you had this brother who
wanted to marry her
you know and now she's completely
writing him off because she only wants
one man to herself
yeah
you know
i know that we'll get some comments
why should women have to settle
how dare you shame women into accepting
polygamy
who are you to say x y and z
and
i have said this before and i'm gonna
say this again
at the end of the day brother sister you
can do whatever you want
you can do whatever you want it
literally is a free world
of course you have to
you know answer to allah at the end of
it but at the end of the day
you can do whatever you want but
understand that the laws of the world
will not change for you
and every choice you make
there is a consequence and everything
that you say yes to or no to there's a
price to pay
so
no one will shame you into accepting a
politionist marriage no one can coerce
you into accepting that but just
understand that if you refuse it there's
a price to pay
just like if you accept it there's going
to be a price to pay you know what i'm
saying so people
nowadays
when you mention
what is better in the sight of allah
what is more virtuous what is more noble
people say stop shaming me
yeah stop stop you know like it's you
know basically stop shaming me and and
and making me feel bad that i'm not
doing things your way no
no one's trying to make you feel bad
it's just the reality is that
in this life there are choices and there
are consequences so in the example that
you gave angel
that sister is perfectly within her
rights to refuse that brother on the
basis that she wants to be the only wife
however the price that she pays could be
that she misses out on a marriage that
would have served her very well
masha'allah and may not get another
offer like that
if you're prepared for that eventuality
sis own it but we don't want you out
here on these streets complaining
that's what we don't want we don't want
you out here on these streets
complaining oh these brothers this
doesn't no no no no no you were you
someone made you an offer
it was not to your liking you couldn't
see your way clear to accepting the
offer that's the choice you made if that
means how lost your your
you don't get married until the end of
your life you have to accept that that
was a choice i made
and i made that choice knowing that i
may not get another offer like this but
i think maybe many of us
we are not realistic about what's
possible for us right we're not
realistic about what's possible and
maybe we've got a certain amount of
fairy tale going on
and we think that the world is full of
great men
just like maybe men think the world is
full of great women i don't know but
what i do know is the older you get
the less select you are not even about
age really just the less select you are
the the smaller the pool
so you have to decide for yourself am i
ready to compromise because i want to be
married or will i keep my standards and
maybe not get married whichever one is
up to you no one's going to tell you
it's up to you and like you said in the
first podcast
you want something right you have a
certain ideal to certain like
requirements of what you want but do you
match that like are you worthy of that
you know
yeah so if the woman has
two kids
and she wants a man just to herself okay
hold us like you said beautiful you have
the right to do that
but
are you worthy of that like
look into reality like is the reality of
that like
do you
deserve that and like if so why do you
deserve that okay that's why then let's
see what happens if if that comes into
fruition
even this whole thing of deserving right
does anyone deserve anything really
yeah i was i was going to say that too
but i had to have no no
you got the right one you got the right
word because it is how people think
i deserve this i deserve that i've done
this i deserve that and the reality is i
think we can all agree that the minimal
that any human being deserves is to be
treated with respect right
that's like the baseline
as for being romantic being expressive
being emotionally available being this
and all of these other things oh that's
all nice to haves but the basis we can
say everybody deserves respect like
nobody deserves to be treated unkindly
and treated you know in a way that is
that is that is not acceptable to any
human being but
sisters
are going to i i
i want to end on this really because i
think
i've seen enough
tick tocks of
older women
yeah
complaining
about the outcomes
that they have
earned really right
they've made certain choices and as a
result of those choices they now are
living with the outcomes and they're not
happy
and they are complaining
and
i don't want our sisters to end up like
that that's what i keep saying is that
take the lesson from the people who went
before you these women out here are not
happy
these women who are leaving the fathers
of their children because they want to
find themselves because they're no
longer happy or because they don't feel
seen or heard and all of these emotional
things
they're not happy because guess what
there is not a long line of eligible
suitors waiting to wife you after you've
left the father of your children that's
just the reality
anyway yeah that's perfect advice for
the muslim men as well because if we go
back to what we were talking about
the red pill
and all this stuff and
the young muslim brothers you know like
living in
in a society which is integrated so they
kind of they make this fault of taking
the red pill as the main program in
islam and the add-on
like what you said right there
is the perfect advice for
for brothers who say oh well without the
reptile how am i going to how am i going
to know how am i going to understand
like how a woman is and all these
experiences and how she actually listen
you take the wisdom and experience from
others
you don't have to make those same
experiences yourself and when you go
into red pill that's what you're doing
anyways you you're taking the wisdom and
experiences of others so why not do that
in the frame of islam why not actually
talk to other brothers who have been
successful do this who have had multiple
marriages who who have been through all
these experiences who've been through
all these troubles it's like from there
you can get
real guidance
we need the brothers to start speaking
more honestly inshallah so hopefully
when you guys come on my podcast we'll
be able to talk about some of these
things insha'allah business
so that was the um
that was the back take you ready for the
the real podcast now
that's a good one thank you so much guys
that was really interesting conversation
i'm sorry that i went on like i tend to
do that and please forgive me because i
said to fayette last time
i wanted it to be more of a conversation
rather than me just going on yeah that's
just usually our best compositions are
the ones that are unscripted and
unplanned kind of like this for those of
you watching that didn't know we
actually didn't plan on this episode it
was something completely different but
allah subhanallah so with that being
said rami do your thing with that being
said allah
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too
like we're more willing to stick through
with things that we set out with an
intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so my love bless you for that first of
all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing stocks shares
bonds you want to be investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas
we will go in with our final three with
brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm